all right here we go this is iphone 13
one iphone and iphone 13 mini and two
this is iphone 13 pro three and iphone
13 pro max four but also apple watch
series seven and this is the all new
ipad mini yes on tuesday apple streamed
a pretty jam-packed infomercial i mean
virtual fall event and it touted all its
new iphones and watches as the usual
legendary spectacular incredible
breathtaking these are the best iphones
we've ever created now of course these
new iphone 13 models are the best
iphones since last year's iphones which
they look almost exactly like but that
doesn't mean there aren't some
significant camera screen and battery
upgrades like last year this was all
virtual so i didn't get to check out the
actual products after the event look a
new iphone it's just like the old iphone
it's very exciting but i do have some
thoughts on everything let's break it
down all of the phones basically have
the same design as last year's iphone 12
except for one thing the notch is
slightly smaller the most secure facial
authentication in a smartphone fits into
a space that's 20 percent smaller oh and
different colors
they all have new a15 bionic chips which
are of course faster than last year's
chips and you know good for things like
gaming and augmented reality as apple
says there's nothing in the world like
this chip
really nothing
and yes all these phones connect to 5g
cellular networks which let me tell you
i rarely use on my current iphone 12. so
what's actually different between these
four new phones
mostly price screens and camera features
let's run down the models from lowest
cost to highest number one the iphone 13
mini starting at 6.99
the mini like last year's mini has a 5.4
inch screen it also has two new cameras
the first is a new wide 12 megapixel
camera which apple says allows in 47
more light the ultra wide camera apple
says provides more detail in dark areas
with less noise
it and all the other new iphones have a
new cinematic video mode this is similar
to portrait mode for photos but it blurs
elements in the background or foreground
as you're shooting
it does this automatically or you can
manually adjust it looks really cool but
i've gotta test it out to see how well
it works
the biggest upgrade to the mini apple
says it has a bigger battery which
should provide one and a half hours more
battery life than last year's model this
is very welcome news since last year's
mini struggled to get through the day
number two the iphone 13 starting at
7.99
this is an easy one the iphone 13 is
actually the same as the mini except
with a 6.1 inch screen plus a bigger
battery that promises two and a half
hours more battery life than last year's
iphone 12. that's it a hundred dollars
more for a bigger screen and longer
battery life
number three the iphone 13 pro starting
at 9.99 the iphone pro also has a 6.1
inch screen but it's made from more
premium materials than those regular
iphone 13 models
the biggest differences come in cameras
and screens
this phone has a new super retina xtr
display with promotion
so many marketing words but the
promotion part is new it means the
screen has up to 120 hertz refresh rate
which will make things like scrolling
and gaming smoother
the camera improvements were the most
interesting things announced today the
pro models have three cameras all with
new sensors with improved noise
reduction
the ultra wide has a new autofocus
system for brighter and sharper shots
it's also capable of a macro mode for
really close up crisp shots
the wide camera will provide a massive
improvement in low light photos apple
says and the telephoto camera has a 3x
optical zoom making a total zoom range
from the ultra wide to the telephoto of
6x basically lots of zoom the pro also
gets a bigger battery promising one and
a half hours longer than the iphone 12
pro
number four the iphone 13 pro max
starting at 10.99 the promax has the
same design and components as that other
pro but it steps it up with a bigger 6.7
inch promotion screen it also has a
bigger battery apple says it will last
two and a half hours longer than last
year's max which is pretty insane since
that phone already lasts a day and then
some and if all of that isn't enough for
you apple will keep selling the iphone
11 two iphone 12 models and the iphone
se at reduced prices
next there's a new apple watch series 7
which starts at 3.99 it has a 20 larger
screen and a slightly new design with
rounder and quote-unquote softer edges
but other than the size there really
isn't much new here oh wait apple is
actually saying it is the most durable
apple watch we've ever built it also
charges 33 faster and fear not apple is
still keeping around the apple watch se
and the series 3. the apple watch series
7 will launch later this fall for lovers
of small tablets there's finally good
news a new ipad mini starting at 4.99
its design is similar to the ipad air
and pro ipads the 8.3 inch screen
stretches all the way to the edges don't
worry the fingerprint sensor now lives
in the power button it's got an a15
bionic processor and new cameras too
plus support for the apple pencil 2
which is still sold separately
apple also updated the regular ipad with
an a13 bionic processor 64 gigabytes of
storage and a 12 megapixel front-facing
camera for the same 329 dollar starting
price so yeah a lot of things if you're
unsure about which is best for you or
you're on the fence deciding between one
or two of the models we'll have full
reviews in the next few weeks i'm
particularly excited about testing all
those iphone battery claims
and all those crazy camera tricks